i know a lot of you out there are
shopping you're worrying about getting
gifts for the season
and it's no secret that this holiday
season
one of the most sought after products is
sony's new playstation 5.
i mean it is almost impossible to get
one of these
they're really in demand and that's why
our own andy richter
i'm told has an exciting announcement
andy that's right conan
listen up video game fans i'm giving
away a ps5
are you serious you really are that's
impressive how did you manage to get
your hands on one
i didn't conan i don't i don't get it
what do you mean
well i called sony and i asked them to
send me a ps5 and they said
absolutely not but my ps5 giveaway
solves that problem by using playstation
math
[Music]
enter now and you could win either a ps2
and a ps3
two ps2s and a ps1 five ps1s
or two ps3s but you have to send me your
ps1
wait so you're not really giving away a
ps5
well no but see each of those prizes
equals a ps5 and that's basically the
same thing right
okay so for example a ps4 and a ps1
no ps4s are still pretty expensive
but i mean if someone wins they can
choose to send me their ps4
and i'll send them nine ps1s
four ps2s and a ps1 two ps3s
one ps2 and a ps1 or
a ps2 a ps1 and four handheld psps
i figure one psp is about one and a half
of a ps1
i'm it's really confusing and that's
just for the second place winner
the grand prize winner will receive the
equivalent of two ps5s
10 ps2 sawed in half enter to win at
teamcoco.com not a real contest
slash fake slash enter slash giveaway
bs5 hyphen sony slash equal sign
question mark question mark pound sign
slash space
heather
god you're just gonna piss people off
and then i'm the one that takes the heat
i'm over acting
you